well I mean what we know is it blacks
and whites see the world vastly
differently I don't want to say that one
group is Miss perceiving the other
because I suspect that there's always a
little bit of truth to all of our
misperceptions of one another that they
they grow out of seeds or kernels of
some part that's true but that we fail
to ask the question what truth are
missing so I'll just give you a quick
example of that sometimes we talk about
hip-hop music and the ways that hip-hop
is a misogynist and nasty towards black
women one of the central elements of
that is calling black women gold diggers
and suggesting that when black men get
rich as hip-hop artists or as athletes
that it's somehow black women who are
benefitting from it right there they're
taking the money in the status and I
always say come on now what truth is
missing there when black men get rich
from entertainment and from athletics
who gets rich with them my students kind
of stare at me so come on who gets rich
when black men become rich through
athletics and through hip-hop music is
it black women who get rich with them
and they go oh no actually it's white
men right so there's all of these white
men attorneys and promoters and right
they're the ones who get rich so who's
the gold digger right so in other words
it's not as though there's no story
there but that we often sort of miss the
rest of the truth so I think the same
thing is true across the racial divide
right that you know sure are there are
there white people who are nasty racist
absolutely right but there's there's a
lot of other truths that are missing
there are there black men who are
frightening criminals absolutely but
there's a lot of truths that are missing
there right so what we do know is that
blacks and whites perceive the world
vastly differently on a number of
different topics so we can look at not
only racial issues like support for
affirmative action where you have
african-americans a majority of African
Americans poor and middle-class
supporting affirmative action vast
majority of whites not supporting
affirmative action you can look at
attitudes towards the past presidents
george w bush before 2005
getting a great deal of support among
white Americans almost no support at all
among african-americans Ronald Reagan
great deal of support among white
Americans very little among
african-americans similarly write a
minority although a plurality of white
Americans having strong support for Bill
Clinton vast majority of African
Americans showing strong support for
Bill Clinton Hurricane Katrina is a
great contemporary example black and
white Americans both extremely angry
about how the federal government
responds to Hurricane Katrina in 2005
but when you ask white Americans about
why they're angry they tell you things
like bureaucratic inefficiency or you
know just sort of not doing the right
thing state and and federal government
getting their signals crossed when you
ask african-americans what they're angry
about they say the government hates
black people right that we were allowed
to suffer and die because of race so
everybody angry and yet two very
different stories about the driving
forces so there are these very real
perceptual differences but I think when
we when we think about the life liberty
and pursuit of happiness questions these
are in part about perceptions and public
opinion but also a great deal about
structure so for example universal
health care would solve the problem of
health care access for black Americans
but also by the way solve the problems
health care access for white Americans
right so what is good in this case for
black people is good for the country
generally if we think about wealth right
this sort of argument that I made about
the vast differences in wealth well you
know that wealth gap is a government
created entity when you look at America
in about nineteen thirty-five or
nineteen forty there is no substantial
thriving white middle-class there's
mostly a white working-class in a white
ownership or wealthy class that
middle-class that wealth gap right now
is driven primarily by the beneficiaries
of the GI Bill the FHA the interstate
transportation act so in other words in
the years following World War two our
federal government look
out at the greatest generation and said
to its citizens you served your country
well in response your country is going
to invest in human capital through the
GI Bill in hard capital through the FHA
which will provide for you and your
family moderately priced homes in good
communities and neighborhoods where you
can send your children to reasonable
public schools and by the way we'll
build high quality interstates between
your homes in these new suburban
communities and into the cities where
you will be able to actually come in and
work and then return to your homes that
those sets of policies of human capital
excuse me human capital transportation
and hard capital in the form of housing
were very real government based
investments into a population and
overnight one generation 20 years you
had a middle-class that did not
previously exist but because of the way
those federal laws were written they
allowed state governments particularly
in the south to not make those lending
decisions not make those GI Bill
investments with African American
soldiers who had served so what that
means is that right at that moment of
investment which has now grown over the
generations this is a large part of that
11 times wealth gap is a result of
really really terrific government
programs that invested in their people
what we need is the same kind of
investment now targeted specifically at
those groups that were left out so you
just say look we're going to invest in
your human capital through college
education right forgivable grants
instead of these high-priced loans that
force people to go into jobs in order to
pay them back we're going to make sure
that you can have moderately priced good
housing in communities that have
reasonable public schools and by the way
we're going to invest in the
transportation infrastructure to get you
to the jobs where they need to be we've
done it before we could do it again and
again within 20 years 40 years I suspect
we see huge returns on that kind of
investment
you